[Music]  guardians  of the galaxy  you came here seeking truth  rejoice  the matriarch wishes  to share it with you  united in the light of belief all  suffering all grief will end  oh  what's wrong with you oh i think  yeah i think i'm having a heart attack  cease this at once  cosmo how are you doing buddy  grand unifier  leader of the church of truths during  that ritual with the priests they kept  talking about a promise  it was like they were drinking funky  juice or something or joined the cult so  let us investigate for you always catch  and not fun-kind with bull  hey world mind long time no see the  current probability of defeating the  universal church of truth is 0.3  is that bad  it sounds  i hope you've got one hell of a speech  plan peter that makes two of us  by rejecting the promise  you have proven yourselves unworthy and  you must be destroyed  that was completely intentional the  milano's on her way  thanks bud  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]